DAVE DAY: Good afternoon
everyone.
My name's Dave and
this is Patrick.
PATRICK HOFMANN: Hi there.
DAVE DAY: And today we'll
be talking about design
principles for Maps.
So we're really hoping we'll get
right back to the basics.
We'll talk about some of the
fundamentals of design.
So our presentation today is
very pure, it's very basic.
There's not too many
flashy demos or
animations to blow you away.
But hopefully, we can give you
some insights in ways you can
improve the design of your map
and also the page around it.
So as I said, my name's Dave
and I'm a JavaScript tamer.
I'm one of the engineers
on the Google
Maps API down in Sydney.
And this is Patrick, and
honestly, I don't think anyone
in the office knows
what he does.
PATRICK HOFMANN: I'm a UX
designer, User Experience
Designer on Google Maps and lots
of things on the local
side of things.
And thanks for the intro.
We are two different eggs.
I hurl things at him
and I say, is
this technically possible?
He goes, no.
But seriously, this picture
isn't all that accurate.
I've actually got the world's
biggest zip as of yesterday on
my nose and I hope the
camera catches it.
And also, outrageous stress
stains or pit stains there.
So just to make sure that's
all accurate and clear.
I also wanted to mention two
different eggs in that at
Google we're constantly trying
to figure out nuances of who
our users are.
And when we're designing, we
just don't design in a bubble.
We actually conduct lots of
usability research, and trying
to figure out, not just
demographically who our users
are, but what do they
fundamentally want to get out
of life and out of
our products.
I wanted to introduce a
different set of users and
that's two different
eggs here.
I'm a triplet, which is odd.
My brother and I are identical,
my sister is
obviously fraternal.
So you get two eggs, one split,
you get the picture.
There is your biology lesson.
But because we're genetically
virtually the same,
are we the same user?
Are the three of us all
going to interpret a
map in the same way?
Are we going to look at icons on
the map and interpret them
in exactly the same way?
And the fundamental
answer is no.
Any experiences that
we had between the
ages of four or 17--
puberty is ravaging--
and then up until we were 40, we
have all these experiences.
We all read different books, go
to different websites, look
at different TV programs,
whatever.
And all of those stimuli have
a fundamental impact on how
we're going to interpret
the map.
However, ironically, our
differences in vision and in
eyesight might also contribute
to how we interpret
a map and so on.
But the fundamental principles
are still relatively the same.
When we design, we are still
trying to shave nanoseconds
and milliseconds off of
your processing time.
We want to get you to
the information
as quickly as possible.
So how can we fundamentally
do that?
And so I want to pose this
question to you, what does
this map say?
It's kind of difficult to see.
And so one could conduct a lot
of usability tests and in lab
usability studies and so on, but
one of the easiest ways,
if you're integrating any type
of information into your
content, especially map
content, is to squint.
And look at that picture
up there and
intentionally try to blur it.
And what do you see?
You see snow.
Snow was probably, that big
blotch of white, is probably
the most prominent thing on the
map if you were to squint.
And in squinting actually
there's a bit of obscuring
happening and so on.
But in actual fact, is the
snow the most important
element or most appropriately
a prominent
element on the map?
And in this case, it isn't.
This map is trying to show all
of the spottings of Godzilla,
Bigfoot, and Sasquatch in the
Western United States.
In actual fact, if that's the
message of my map, I should be
trying to elevate those
components.
And the photographic
information, that rich
satellite imagery in the
background, is too prominent
and it's competing too
much with that
information on the map.
And that's one of the
fundamental principles.
And yes it's common sense,
but it's one that we are
constantly asking
all the time.
And that is, what should
the map be saying?
So what are the foundational
design
principles in getting there?
And fundamentally, it's CRAP.
So it's designing with CRAP.
I'm going to talk about
things beyond CRAP.
And Dave's going to pipe in
about how we actually apply
all of these rules.
So what is CRAP exactly?
And I don't take credit
for CRAP.
Robin Williams takes
credit for CRAP.
Robin Williams, not the
comedian, but the wonderful
author who wrote "The
Non-Designer's Design Book"
back in 2003.
And what she did was
fundamentally break down the
principles of design, really
where design meets usability.
And she had said, she
pontificated this, she said
the purpose of design is to
communicate, to organize, and
to attract.
So we don't create designs just
to make them sit there
and look pretty.
There's this fundamental
message that has to be
conveyed in anything
that we design.
We want as much as possible to
guide the human eye through a
space in a very, very
appropriate way.
And we often refer to this space
that the human eye goes
through as rivers
of information.
And those rivers tend to meander
and they tend to
obscure and they tend
to pop out at you.
How can we guide the eye to the
place that we want users
to go to most?
And how do we maintain
their attention?
How can we avoid them from
clicking away to soon before
they found the information that
they were looking for?
So where does CRAP fit in?
Well CRAP stands for contrast,
repetition,
alignment, and proximity.
And those, for me personally, I
really follow these rules as
much as possible.
On a map where you've got lots
of unpredictable data, it's
really, really hard to say,
well how do I introduce
alignment when my
data doesn't?
I can't just say all of these
buildings on this street
should be aligned.
But in actual fact, there are
ways of ensuring that you can
get your users to the
information in the right way.
So let's start with contrast.
One more time.
There we go.
Contrast is a pretty simple
fundamental principle.
And that is, if you've got
different information types on
the page, you want to make those
different information
types distinct from
one another.
And contrast, whether it be
through color, through stroke,
through weight, through
saturation or tone, those
things will help make the
contrast different elements
from one another.
So you'll look at this map and
you've got primary roads,
you've got secondary roads,
you've got information off the
map, and hopefully, you'll
notice that this was a very,
very, very old screenshot
of Google Maps.
This is actually about
from two and a half
to three years ago.
We've come a long way baby, as
you noticed this morning.
So what we try to do is make
sure, especially on the map,
that transit stops, for example,
embody a type of
contrast, that roads have a
certain type of contrast so
that they're distinguishable
from the base layer, that
Links in the left hand column,
as you can see, are
distinguishable from non-linked
content and
so on and so on.
And so what we try to do is
contrast is one of those
fundamental principles
that we always use.
One of the things that's really,
really important is
that if you've got high contrast
colors that are
really, really close to each
other like red and green or
red and blue, they can often
cause a lot of visual
dissonance.
And so we try to avoid those
as much as possible.
But in this case, generally
speaking, contrast is all
about making the information
components distinguishable
from one another.
And here is how much we've
transformed from two and a
half years ago to yesterday.
This morning you saw something
dramatically different.
And that's taking things a
beautiful step further where
the new Google Maps that you saw
this morning are actually
even a more toned down version
of the map that you see here.
And again, here's a map of
Bangalore, India from about
two and a half years ago.
And you can see how thick
and bold the roads were.
And all of those thickly stroked
roads seem to be the
most prominent thing
on the map.
And we really, really, really
toned it down to make sure
that there wasn't this huge
colorful assault on the eye
because it really made things
hard to scan and hard to read
because everything seemed to
be the same saturation
and the same tone.
So contrast is fundamentally
important.
What about repetition?
Repetition is an easy one too
and it's quite similarly
related to contrast.
And that is, if you've got all
the different information
types that you've got on your
page, headings, links, body
text, and on the map you've
got points of interest,
primary roads, secondary roads,
neighborhood names, all
of those are different
information types.
If you give one of them a style,
make sure that that
style is repeated all
the way through.
And yes, that's common sense.
I know that, but it's one of
those principles that we
always seem to fail.
We keep adding exceptions
to every rule.
And repetition, the foundational
principle of
repetition, reminds us that
we should not keep adding
differences or exceptions
to these rules.
So it's like creating a style
sheet and following it as much
as possible.
Robin Williams had the argument
that too much
repetition can be boring, too
much repetition can be boring,
too much repetition can be
boring, too much repetition
can be boring.
On a map, that repetition
is required.
It's the style guide.
It's the style sheet.
It's the visual lexicon that we
want to remind users of as
they scan a map of Bangalore
versus a map of San Francisco
versus a map of Sydney,
Australia.
We want to make sure that they
can easily scan the map and
without any effort, they know
what a point of interest is
versus a different type of
landmark versus a road versus
a neighborhood.
Of all of those different
information types that fill
the page, we try as much as
possible to ensure that that
style guide remains intact.
Alignment on the map, again
as I said before,
is a bit of a problem.
Off the map, it's fundamental to
creating these rivers that
guide the eye through
the page.
And we don't just position
things on the page just
arbitrarily.
What we actually try to do is
follow a grid system, or in
addition to the grid system,
trying to make sure that
things align with
other things.
So buttons being in place,
they're not just sort of two
or three or four pixels off.
It might seem like that two
or three or four pixels in
dissonance is not that big a
deal, but in actual fact, it
adds weight or slowness
to how we scan a page.
And if we keep things aligned,
it adds a basic uniformity to
the page and a basic
unity to the page.
And that's why we've got these
rivers of the 40 pixels of
white text to the left hand
side of the left hand
panel and so on.
Last, not last, but not least.
Off a map, look, I encourage you
go out, look in any of our
Google I/O content, whether it's
digital or in print, go
out and look at the
bus shelters.
If you see advertisements
in the bus shelters, the
positioning of all of those
elements, especially in an
advertisement, are
not arbitrary.
Look for those invisible
lines.
And you'll notice that nothing
is as arbitrary or as random
as it seems.
In this case, I actually tried
to create some alignment with
the elements of my face
in that photograph.
And so, again, it's
not arbitrary.
And what it does, as I
said before, is add
unity to the page.
Proximity is the last bit, and
that is all about putting
things that are of like
importance or like meeting
closer to one another so that
we can identify groups of
information so that the
can scan things.
If you're not interested in
looking at a bunch of links,
then we can immediately scan
past that group of four links
on the left hand side.
If you're interested in photos,
wow, it's great that
we grouped all of those photos
and put them really, really
closely together.
Yes, it sounds like common
sense, but it's one of those
principles where if you're
trying to decide how to space
your information, group the
information like elements of
information more closely
together.
And what this does is it shaves
those nanoseconds and
milliseconds of processing
time and scanning
time off of your user.
So beyond CRAP, there's
other things
other than CRAP, obviously.
We have some other general
design principles when it
comes to Maps.
If you're putting Maps on your
site, if you're creating
mobile applications and so on,
obviously size matters.
I had a really, really awesome
sexy slide here but I
had to remove it.
Again, it's trying to be
adaptive to the devices,
thinking about the destination
device that you're using, the
size of the map fundamentally
matters.
But in those fluctuations of
size, you have to ask yourself
how much information does the
user need at any given time?
If I have a map on my phone
should I be showing a
different type of information
than the map
that's on my desktop?
What can I take away in that
smaller amount of real estate?
And Dave is going to provide
some examples later.
On the desktop side, you'll
notice like at sites like
Google Flights, that default map
really is quite a lovely
stripped down version
of a map.
We don't need to show all of the
state names on that map.
We can just show the slight
little nuances of political
borders, show the origin and
destination, and make that the
most prominent thing on the map,
and everything else on
that map is very, very,
very much muted.
Again, with the exception of
some wonderful little helpful
serendipitous destination names,
they say, hey on that
budget I could fly to Billings
or I could fly to Portland,
Oregon or whatever.
So we try to really, really
strip back the
information on that map.
And again, try to keep
everything above the fold,
especially in this case.
And above the fold is a reminder
to us that position
is not just about size, but
also about position.
So make sure, obviously, that
people do not need to scroll
down the page.
Try to keep everything
above the fold.
And again, on the mobile side
of things, above the fold
usually means it's going to take
over the entire screen
real estate.
But again, it's often in a lot
of sites we notice that that's
a consideration that's
often overlooked.
Not only do size and position
matter, but message.
A map isn't there just
to physically exist.
Always, always ask what the
primary message of the map is.
So this is a stationary
map that you see here.
I photographed it in
Christchurch, New Zealand as I
was approaching the Christchurch
Botanic Gardens.
And the first thing I
wanted to know was,
where the heck am I?
There were all these different
entrances on the map and I
couldn't quite see where
I was on that map.
That little red thing that
you see there in the
middle of the map--
again, if you do
the blur test--
that red thing does come out
quite prominently, but that
was just an information
center.
But if I can't identify where I
am, how am I going to get to
the information center?
What's also interesting in this
case and this is a trap
that I myself even fallen into
when I do a lot of data
visualization, is if you've
got a lot of data and it
doesn't correspond to the
message of your map, you
really don't need to show it.
This map beautifully,
beautifully illustrates all of
these wonderful trees
that fill the
Christchurch Botanic Gardens.
They're getting in the way of
fundamental element of the
maps, and that is, the pathways
to see those trees.
The pathways to get to the
different areas of the
Christchurch Botanic Gardens.
And it's a beautiful map,
they've done a beautiful job,
but what should the focus
of attention be?
What is a thesis of the map?
It's not just about here's a
[INAUDIBLE] views of trees.
It's how do I guide my users
to those different elements
and places in the park?
So just because you've got a lot
of tree data doesn't mean
you have to show it.
And this leads to this other
principle which is people
don't read a map.
I'm not going to go this is a
tree, this is a tree, this is
a tree, this as a tree,
this as a tree.
I'm going to scan the map to
find out where I am and find
out where I want to go.
So optimize your maps for
scanning as much as you
possibly can.
Distinguish the message or the
thesis of the map from the
base contents of the map.
And in this case, really the
pathways should have been
much, much, much
more prominent.
And in making things easy to
scan, you'll notice that it's
all about taking things away.
It's not necessarily deciding
what you want to add to the
map, but what's the most minimal
form of map I need and
what's the fundamental
information that I can
reintroduce to it.
And so David's going to talk
about that a bit more later.
And as I outlined earlier, the
blur test is a great way of
figuring that out.
So if your message of the map
is, in this case, sighting of
Bigfoot, Sasquatch, and Godzilla
in the Western United
States, wow, if I do this
blurred, those pink markers
really, really blend in the map
way, way, way too much.
They're not the most prominent
thing on the map.
So let's bring them out.
But then if I bring them out,
I need to ask myself a few
other questions.
And that is, if every element
could speak for itself, what
would it say?
I'm a pink marker on a map.
But I want it to say, I'm
Godzilla on the map.
I'm Godzilla on the map.
So here's where you've got a
great opportunity to change
the iconography on
the map as well.
Markers aren't bad, but maybe
adding more information to
those markers would
be a great idea.
Also ask how loud would
that map be talking?
If I reduce this zoom of this
image and I was showing most
of the continental United States
and I had all of these
markers there, those markers
would be like actually rather
large and they would be like
I'm a bunch of markers!
Again, try to test the things
out as much as possible at
multiple zoom levels.
So the blur test and the
vocation test are key.
And we do this a lot.
So make it obvious.
What's the map supposed to say,
sightings of Godzilla,
Sasquatch, and Bigfoot.
But also ask yourself, what are
the outcomes of the map?
What do you want users
to do with this map?
If you want users to
drive to these
sightings, add the roads.
And so here, this doesn't
provide any information.
It's not even showing me
the states that these
sighting are in.
So try to introduce a little
bit more information and a
little bit for more information
and a little bit
more information from a base
empty map, essentially.
And so Dave will get into
that later as well.
And what this ends up with is
a map that's meaningful, but
also so fresh and
so clean clean.
So you've removed visual
traffic, you've distinguished
the meaning of the map from
the base map, and it's
something that, again, is easy
to scan and something that
users will be able to get the
information that they need to
glean from it.
And again, as I said
before, test it at
multiple zooms and regions.
So how do I apply all
these rules, Dave?
DAVE DAY: OK.
So I'm going to be talking about
two major things that
you can be doing as developers
with your map to help make
your map sell its message so
that users can quickly see
what you're trying to explain.
And these fall into two
categories basically.
What are you going to do with
the base map to help this?
And what are you going to do
with the data you put on top?
And mostly, I'll be focusing
on desktop maps in my
examples, but this applies
across the board, whether
you're talking about
mobile or desktop.
Or any way you try and deliver
maps, you have to be asking
yourself both of those
questions.
So when we're talking about the
base map, it's really the
styled map capability that we
introduced a couple of years
ago, which gives you the ability
to customize the
message your map is saying.
And so one thing that we allow
with the styled maps is you
can target specific features
of the map.
For example, you could target
geometries or labels.
And in this case, I've decided
that my map doesn't actually
need the context of maybe road
names or anything, I'm really
interested in the geometries.
So I've targeted the labels and
I've turned them all off
on the map.
You can actually be more fine
grained in the way you're
targeting features and target
specific feature types as well
as just elements.
So if we want a little bit of
context for the user so when
they look at it they know hey,
I'm looking at Sydney or I'm
looking at this specific city
or country, then we can turn
those specific labels on, the
administrative labels, I can
turn them back on.
Another way that we can help
change the message of the map
is to reduce the visual noise by
making the features on the
map less distinctive,
less bold.
And in this case, I've turned
down the weighting on all my
roads to 0.8.
So the roads themselves are
taking up much less space and
they're occupying less
of my attention.
And when I was explaining that
we were turning things on or
off, we actually have three
separate states of visibility
in the Google Maps API.
So by default, this is what you
get in the standard map
and that's with your roads
set to visibility on.
There's a second state which
we call a simplified
visibility.
And in this one, we still have
road information, but we've
tried to simplify it as
much as possible.
The geometries are
a little simpler.
We've stripped out the labels.
There are still some
important markers.
There are still some direction
signs, but overall, visually
they're much, much simpler.
And then, of course, you can
turn off the roads altogether.
But as you can probably tell in
this case, that makes this
map useless.
Pretty much useless.
PATRICK HOFMANN: The
map is crap, but a
different type of crap.
DAVE DAY: So you can turn things
on and you can turn
things off.
That's fantastic, but really
the power of it is when you
can start to change
the stylistic
elements of the map too.
So here I've got five
different maps
showing off New York.
And in the first one that's the
standard new Google Maps
that we're showing off.
One of the variables we let
you affect is this hue.
So you can say I'd like my map
or a specific feature to be
colored this way.
So I've asked for
a red New York.
The second variable in the
third panel there is
saturation and that lets you
either tone down the color so
eventually it would wash out
to gray, or if you want the
opposite effect and you really
want to make something vibrant
because that is the message that
you're trying to send,
then you can scale it right
up for bright colors.
The fourth panel is showing off
lightness, which is where
we could either scale the map
right out to a white, or at
the other extreme, it would
scale it make it completely
dark and black.
And so this way, again, you can
adjust how much contrast
is on your map and which
elements are standing our or
fading away.
And the last variable we
have is allowing you
to invert the lightness.
So the traditionally dark
elements of a Google Map
become light and the light
elements become dark.
And it's not until you combine
all those different features
that you can really have control
over what you want
your map to say.
So here's an example of
all those features.
I've chosen a very, very
stark palette.
And again, this is a map of
Sydney, but this is telling a
quite different story
to the one before.
I've emphasizes the highways by
coloring them red and I've
emphasized the secondary roads
by coloring them yellow.
And I've removed a lot of the
labelling and other geographic
information from the map.
So if you were looking at this
map, it's very clear for you
to see how do the roads of
Sydney connect together?
What are the major arterial
roads through Sydney?
How would you get around?
It doesn't give you much other
context, but in the context of
how does the traffic
system work?
It's the perfect map.
Here's another example in New
York where this time we're
trying to emphasize
how the transit
system connects together.
And here, pretty much everything
has been taken out
of the map.
It's a very muted palette.
There's no labels, but we've
turned on transit and that's
brightly colored
with its label.
So it's the feature
of the map.
It's the hero.
One rule of thumb, if you're not
sure, if you are worried
that your map is too busy, is to
try to turn everything off
and then slowly introduce
levels of detail until
everything you want your users
to be able to do with the map
is possible, but none of your
information gets in the way.
So try turning off all
administrative regions or all
labeling, all roads, bring them
back up and see at what
point your data becomes
comfortable.
So you've got your base map
and you're happy with it.
The next thing is, how are
we going to make the
data on that map sing?
How are we going to make it
tell the story that we're
hoping for?
So here I have a beautiful
map of?
Anyone want to hazard a guess?
Somewhere near Paris.
Definitely very French.
It's actually, I'm trying to
highlight the famous cuisine
restaurants of Paris
or France.
In this case, we have three
cuisines that we know the
French are famous for, that's
hamburgers, pizza, and fish.
So where in town should I go
if I want to get a pizza?
Where shall I be?
And again, of course, this
map doesn't give you any
information.
If there was a legend to the
side, you'd spend time
scanning between the two trying
to work out where
exactly all the pizza
restaurants are so you can
wander around.
A little bit of simple
iconography, a little bit of
simple coloring, and all of a
sudden, I don't need to tell
you what the map's about.
I don't need to provide
a legend.
That maps says for itself
exactly where each of these
restaurants are, exactly what
type of food that I'm likely
to find there, and where I
should wander tonight if I'm
after a pizza, a famous
French pizza.
Of course, if I was referencing
these elements
outside my map on the web page
itself, I would use the same
vocabulary and use the same
coloring, the same
iconography, but you can see,
just a simple choice of colors
and shapes already
has made that map
infinitely easier to scan.
Here's another example.
I'd ask you to guess but I
guess you get the point.
This time I'm trying to show
where all the large airports
are in the States.
And instead of using specific
coloring or specific types of
marker to display information,
instead I can use vector
symbols to give you a sense
of data that goes
into another dimension.
So here, I've placed airplanes
on the map at each of the
major airports in the US and
I've sized that symbol
corresponding to how many people
board planes in that
airport every year.
And so straight away,
again, you know I'm
talking about airplanes.
And you also get a sense
of which airports
are the most important.
It's obvious that Atlanta
is, by far, the
largest hub in the US.
And then you can see things
like LAX and San Francisco
standing out.
And in terms of code,
this isn't an
impossible task at all.
It's actually quite simple.
Really I've started with a
vector path that Patrick,
beautiful designer that he
is, designed for me.
And then it was a simple little
bit of math where I
took how many passengers went
through that airport annually,
divided it by the maximum, and
scaled it so I had a number
between, I think I went between
a quarter and one and
a quarter so I had a good
range of sizes.
And then, as I created the
marker, I just gave it that
vector path and I told it
how large its scale
was supposed to be.
And it was that simple
to add that level of
information onto the map.
Now sometimes, as Patrick said
with the trees, you have
beautiful data, but putting it
all on the map at once is not
going to help your
users at all.
This is a little screenshot from
the Google Hotel Finder.
And you can see that or you can
imagine that hotels have a
lot of variables associated
with them.
What star rating at they?
What the users think of them?
How costly are they?
Are they available right now?
Do they have a pool?
What brand are they?
And if we tried to come up with
a language in our icons
or our symbols that expressed
every single one of those
variables, again, we'd have the
user scurrying backwards
and forwards between a really
complicated legend on one side
of the map and a complicated
map with a lot of
information on it.
And it would take them a long
time to try and decipher what
it is they were trying to
get out of the map.
So sometimes the simplest
decision is to not make a
decision at all and let the user
be the one that drives
the experience.
So you can target specific hotel
groups, prices, star
ratings, that you're interested
in, reduce the
data, and then it's very simple
for the user to scan
that and find what they need.
PATRICK HOFMANN: Takeaways.
Reminding me of food
in Paris and so on.
We're doing very good on time.
So a few takeaways.
Obviously, you saw the
presentation this morning on
the new Google Maps and
as I said before, it's
come a long way baby.
If you're creating your own
maps especially trying to
build and visualize your own
data, it's amazing to see how
much process and how much
thought has to go into or
analysis that needs
to go before you
even get to the design.
And so this is just
a few examples--
and this is in a previous
redesign of Maps where we just
covered walls upon walls
with lots of--
and sorry to all the forests
and trees out there in the
making of this redesign--
but it's amazing.
If you take stock and you really
catalog all of the
things that are on a map, it's
compelling, it's overwhelming.
But you have to take
stock of them.
And that refers to all the
information types I was
talking about earlier.
And so as you're assembling
different types of data, and
in this case we've got like
transit icons, municipal
transit icons, it's amazing to
see what role they play.
And again, that role they play
is dependent upon the type of
map that you're creating.
And so as you take stock of
those elements and information
types, you begin to decide,
OK, how prominent should
transit be on a map
of San Francisco?
Or on a map of Prague?
Or on a map of Sydney,
Australia?
And so if you want those
elements to really, really pop
out, of that contributes to the
effective meaning of your
map, then make those components
high contrast.
So taking stock of the elements
and information
types, what it does is it
forces you to prioritize
what's most important
and least important.
What should be really, really
high contrast on the top of
the map and what should be
fundamentally burned into the
map in a little bit more subtle
or lower contrast.
Also take stock of the colors.
When we first went through the
redesign exercise, I think it
was something in the
neighborhood, we had like 350
different colors on Google Maps
and it was like, why so
many when the color wheel, even
the color wheels that
we're showing here don't
have 350 colors?
But we just had all of these
different slight subtle
variations of graphics
and images.
And we were like, in order to
help people scan, in order to
apply that fundamental principle
of repetition, we
couldn't have 350 for 360
forms of repetition.
Let's have eight forms
of repetition.
Right?
Let's have eight primary colors
on the map and let's
use them as much as possible.
And then, if we're going to add
road labels and things,
maybe it'll go up to 16.
But again, it's about taking
stock of all of the different
colors and trying to decide, OK,
what's my smallest palette
going to be.
And try to establish a
consistent policy just like
you would establish a very,
very strict style sheet in
your content.
Take stock of the strokes,
not the band, but the
elements of the map.
So there are tons and tons of
line segments on a map and as
we build ways of guiding the
eye through the map and
realizing that those strokes
are totally unpredictable,
they're going to take different
shapes, different
directions, how can we
fundamentally move forward in
a way that's going to work
for the entire planet?
And in this case, you'll see a
map of, I think it's Emmaus,
Pennsylvania on the left in
about, I think it was 2010,
another one in 2013,
and another
one as of this morning.
And things have fundamentally
changed.
And its all because we're
trying to improve the
experience, trying to give
people the information that
they need at any given time,
and trying to satisfy those
fundamental principles,
which are CRAP, right?
Contrast, repetition, alignment,
and proximity.
Don't forget it.
Also remember that
maps aren't read.
People don't read maps,
they scan them.
And ask yourself who
is your user?
Is it going to be my brother?
Is it going to be my sister?
Is it going to be me?
Is it going to be someone with
really, really good eyesight
or really, really
poor eyesight?
And irrespective of that, how
are they going to use that map
that you stick in
front of them?
And try to emphasize what
that message is.
That message of the
map is the thesis.
It's the focus of attention and
those design choices you
make should be built
upon that thesis.
But if anything, no matter what
the message of the map is
and so on, try to minimize
that visual traffic.
It's amazing to see in eye
tracking studies how much the
eye pops back and forth on a map
when you give them certain
different levels of stimuli,
different colors, and so on.
But again, in an effort to avoid
all of that testing and
so on for you, just do the
blur test and you can see
where you're headed.
And that's about it.
So we are three minutes
ahead of schedule.
So if you have any questions,
please come up to the mic and
we're happy to answer
any of them.
AUDIENCE: Hey there.
My name is Yarin, and I wanted
to ask Dave, you're a
JavaScript programmer,
correct?
DAVE DAY: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to know if
any of these features like
removing the rows or changing
the colors or any of these
things are available
on Android.
And if they're not, is there
any plan for that?
DAVE DAY: At the moment they're
not currently available.
We don't have the styled map
typing in Android yet.
But definitely, that's something
we're interested in.
Obviously, the styling, as we
saw, is a really important way
of telling a story.
So at the moment, we've focused
those on the desktop.
But watch this space.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Mohamed.
You guys made a lot of really
great points about the map
design and some great
tips about the pins.
I was wondering if you had
anything to share about call
out design?
I've noticed that you guys have
started to move away from
the kind of the pop up call out
and you're doing something
slightly different, well
actually, very different on
the mobile apps and now
also on the web.
Thanks.
PATRICK HOFMANN: Yeah.
So the call out is an
interesting one in that
especially when you're working
with small areas of real
estate like on Mobile, the
call out ends up becoming
something that you transition
usually laterally from side to
side or up and down.
And so what's really important
in that space is to always
provide that tiny little bit
of the teaser that says the
call out is going to happen if
you come down in the space or
if I swipe across this space.
And it's always to provide
the before and after.
So the before being that little
call to action or that
little visual indicator that
says there's going to be more
information beyond here.
And as soon as that transition
occurs, there's going to be an
easy way for me to get back
to that original view.
So that permanence or prominence
of that before and
after, that teaser that says
here's my destination and
here's my way back is really,
really important in that small
piece of real estate.
As you saw this morning, you'll
notice that photos that
are added to maps or it was, I
believe this morning you may
have seen the the Basilica in
Vatican City, and you'll
notice that we have
this new style of
call outs which point.
So we have an actual grid of
information, so a bunch of
thumbnails at the bottom of the
map and pointing to the
elements on the map, as opposed
to having huge info
windows that say hey this photo
exists here and this
photo exists here and this photo
photo exists here.
So we've noticed that there's
ways of, again, following the
fundamental principle of
proximity, of grouping the
information away from it.
So take all of those--
because photos and thumbnails
are actually quite visually
rich, taking those photos and
actually grouping them
together and just providing
those annotation lines or call
out lines to that information.
And so to me, those are the two
fundamental principles or
the biggest most significant
changes that we've seen.
I think for Mobile is probably
the more challenging because
of the limitations
in real estate.
But those are two examples
anyway of how we've sort of
overcome the problem.
Because you know how prominent
our info windows or call outs
used to be.
We've come a long way baby.
Yes.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi, Patrick,
a fellow UXer.
I appreciate keeping
the faith.
With respect to the data
visualization the extent to
which Maps is becoming a kind
of data visualization canvas
that's open to kind of receive
and render data, there are big
enterprise data visualization
things are just like throw
anything at me, I'll
render it.
But your point is it works
better if you actually kind of
curate and think about
the message?
PATRICK HOFMANN: Yep.
AUDIENCE: And where does
are that exist in the
roadmap tool suite?
I know, I understand it could
exist in the raw code, but is
that part of vision for Google
Maps, how it sits with
spreadsheets or other kind of
data serving platforms?
PATRICK HOFMANN:
You've inspired
me to create something.
Because right now,
there isn't--
I mean, the principle
is there.
We want to try to offer you as
much freedom as possible.
We can't ever predict what all
of the messages will be.
Right?
And what all the messages are
at any given piece of data
visualization.
The topics are just too
uncountable and innumerable.
So that said, you've triggered
an interesting little project
in my mind, my next
20% project.
In order to maybe rein in
on some of the actual--
what are the most common sort
of pitfalls in showing too
much information?
And do they fall under a
specific category or genre of
data visualization?
So for example, I did a lot
of work on crisis maps.
And what I noticed was in an
effort to provide the most
accurate information possible,
especially because it usually
involved life threatening
situations like tsunamis and
fires and so on, the
information had to be accurate.
Therefore, it had to
show everything.
I'm like, well, I'm trying to
get through a flood and I need
to show how severe the floods
are, what the height of the
water is, the height of the
water is important, but is
that road impassable given
that height of water?
And so maybe what we need in
those situations in those
genres is the reminders of, what
are you trying to say?
You've inspired me.
Thank you for that.
Yes.
So the answer is no, we don't
have anything yet, but I think
you've inspired me
to do something.
DAVE DAY: So we're actually over
time now, unfortunately,
but if you want to come and grab
us afterwards, we're more
than happy to answer
your questions
and thank you everyone.
PATRICK HOFMANN: Great.
Thank you.